there are two opportunities coming up to
get free medical care in the valley
doctors and dentists are bringing their
services into the communities that need
the most denise joins us now to explain
how you can sign up in today's health
watch denise well you know healthcare
should really be affordable it should be
accessible so anthem wants to reinvent
how health care is being delivered so
this friday the 15th it is bringing
services to north las vegas for a
day-long health fair
for breast cancer awareness month anthem
blue cross and blue shield of nevada is
hosting mammorama in north las vegas
nevada health centers will offer free
exams in its mammovan we chose this
location because we know that there are
barriers to access and routine health
care especially in this area and
especially for women of color but there
will also be a variety of services
available at no cost not only mammograms
but vaccinations vision screening kobit
19 testing health information and other
resources all in one spot without having
to worry about paying for it this event
removes all of that anxiety and those
barriers and says here we are what
services do you need how can we help you
how can we make sure that you have the
very best health care possible the
health fair is this friday 8 a.m to 4
p.m at the martin luther king senior
center near mlk and kerry no appointment
necessary now if you need a cavity
filled or a tooth removed but don't have
the money or the insurance for it you
can get that done free the first weekend
of november
dozens of local dentists and oral
surgeons will donate their time on
saturday november 6th now for this you
must make an appointment by november 3rd
and spots are filling up fast
now that's actually part of the annual
southern nevada
dental society they do a day of service
and there are usually about a dozen
different offices taking part so we do
have a link to make an appointment on
eightnewsnow.com these do go quickly uh
so again this friday is the health fair
with all those services and then in a
couple of weeks free dental care so mark
your calendars back to you guys